how's going bros my name welcome back to
whoa this nothing you got a stud nah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] electronics guys I
hate don't block me I spoke Japanese
before you were born
[ __ ] that's right stabbing stabbing
hey nice pirouette oh no that's a dead
man next session I'm not a mental
patient totally normal
all right boxes are going here
that is nice whoa I got flowers and
since that whoa yeah dude hey you're
actually got a gap you want to go with
me I'll call you Jerry Jerry don't go in
there Jerry you'll die
Jerry be careful please man whatever you
do you're my only friend here Jerry I
love you so much
don't drown yourself bro holy [ __ ] rats
can breathe underwater Jerry you're
amazing
oh I guess he needs air every once in a
while it's just you and me Jerry Jerry
the [ __ ] man you totally bailed on me oh
cool whoa oh don't kill Jerry oh that
[ __ ] turn crank where are they I don't
see any crowd is all right mouse boy aah
that screwing it rip I don't know what
no Jerry screw oh yeah
what are you doing man just stop at the
point thank you
revolver analyst full
what I alright
our battle begins Wow oh it's a big one
not good not good not good
Jerry Jerry Jerry Jerry Jerry Jerry
Jerry Jerry savage of power that's right
[ __ ] you so many so many I like your
face it's really cool why you so big
that's what everyone I slice it Japanese
chopped up chop chop
Jerry help me man that's right get up
hey not me
[ __ ] you you're not the spider bro
you're not the spider that's right
Jerry you're not cool bruh no like this
what is this why why do I not have a
revolver yet I know I missed it but
doesn't mean they see another one
however space to climb high ledges here
alright what bad I don't think I know
what's coming
oh there thank God alright you alright
pull the goddamn trigger already what
the [ __ ] are you
right here Brad take it so long chill
out man I'm not killing anyone
bro
[Music]
Hey whoa I'm Pat eyes oh it wasn't me
well I am pretty badass look at those
sideburns damn a girl
all right that is pretty [ __ ] nasty
ah Siamese twins whoa
Siamese machinegun twin damn I want one
of those mine is better
oh that's right the other two has holes
in them BAM wham wham wham bam no no
should be I come I don't like bullets I
should you say me spin no no shoot em
I'd really don't have much of a tactic
going I guess
this is the best I can do we go the same
direction
nope
[Music]
shut up I'm not your daddy bro oh no no
no no I'm freaking out
alright it's math it's not smash time
slide slightly shut ah Siamese twin I
died I forgot that I drains life I'm
stupid well I got an achievement at
least oh [ __ ] this is so [ __ ] up I'm
I'm just really confused when I play
this you might think I know what I'm
doing ha ha well I probably didn't think
that all right
and we great if we could skip this
country enough all right let's transform
right away that is so disgusting
slicing these big Japanese
I don't even know if I [ __ ] can kill
him
oh is that all right cool yeah yeah bro
are you okay
I mean to kill you i flashbang grenades
they don't even tell you how to use
those I would like to know at least
alright
the field of view is really up in your
ass
whoa I hate you what why
shut up [ __ ] die come on what are you
here huh
this is not good alright transform you
make me angry
can't can't transform I'm screwed come
on where the [ __ ] are you
headshots really doesn't work that well
on us
goddamnit alright I'm transforming it is
[ __ ] disturbing every time slap slap
slap slap alright that's how I roll and
we are back to the handsome gentlemen
shut up stop crying I don't know I'm not
your daddy and sorry it's not good
enough lady shut I can't even open it
it's third person better maybe worse
whoa what the [ __ ] you're not the spider
bro you're not to climb come on really
where do I shoot them they never die I
don't like that hey I didn't brah
oh dude do think of your [ __ ] bro how
come my eyes transforming time its
transform it's coming for you you didn't
know oh I tell you it's coming
transformers
good dude where is it where is it come
here I want hugs many mystery come on
baby that's right whoa dude stop that
[ __ ] this game just turn into a [ __ ]
action game holy [ __ ] just focus in on
killing these [ __ ] [ __ ] die whoa
humph I can't even kill him if I [ __ ] it
please let me out shut your head
shut your vagina shut your titty or
denied you see that [ __ ]
alright come on come on that's not open
where do I go then you come on give me a
break every and that's right high
switching to this because I am really
confused that's not gonna work
how you doin half is there alright why
did I go here something here buzz your
[ __ ] nobody's death happens I got cops
tricking not this nothing hello alright
cool stop stop no flash tool in the
world talk but watch yourself this place
can eat your soul
uh-huh well I don't missus aha
Jimmy you got friends yeah I'm happy for
you oh thank you
already whoa Tommy gun that's a nice
name of a gun
sup Tommy is that you or me or someone
else this climb is ladder like we always
do Tommy
well this ladder is a little too high
it's kind of awkward loading screen like
a bow all right Tommy
it's you and me bro I threw a flag did
you like that Tommy going on in here why
don't you have a head whoa what what no
way
oh my god how does that even work
what if I click on a TV when performing
a lethal injection can have seen show
that the needles replaced with absolute
precision like standard medical
procedures with a lethal injection
you'll have a patient who probably does
not want the procedure to occur it is a
vital importance that they restraints be
tight and strong
I travel may arise incumbent upon the
effect is not a tick matters into his
own hand using all right thank you very
valuable very well and there's beer all
right I want to play a little more it's
me bra bra bra bra bra whoa Wow
all right
[Music]
[ __ ] me [ __ ]